jetzt kommen wir aber zum letzten
ressort für heute zumindest an diesem
ersten tag wie gesagt drei tage lang
soll das ja hier gehen und zu beginn
jeder
aussprache zu einem ressort hat die
zuständige ministerin das wort hier
sehen sie schon steffi lemke von den
grünen dies die ministerin die
ressortchefin für umwelt naturschutz
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz sie sehen ist das
ministerium ist etwas umgebaut worden
und das bestimmt auch die themen
klimaschutz musste steffi lemke aus dem
boden das umweltministerium abgeben das
wirtschafts- und energie und
klimaministerium an robert habeck die
zuständigkeit für verbraucherschutz hat
sie zugeschlagen bekommen aus dem
justizressort und wir hören jetzt ihre
ersten punkte sozusagen ihren ersten
auftritt hier als umweltministerin und
ihre ersten punkte die sie hier
vorstelle was wir sie anpacken in ihrer
zeit als ministerin
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die neue
bundesregierung hat ihre arbeit
aufgenommen ein halbes jahr nachdem das
bundesverfassungsgericht ein
wegweisendes urteil gefällt hat darin
hatte sie der damaligen
regierungskoalition bescheinigt dass sie
die lasten unserer heutigen lebens und
produktionsweise auf jüngere und
kommende generationen verschiebt und
damit die existentiellen freiheitsrechte
dieser generation verletzt werden die
neue bundesregierung ist angetreten das
zu ändern sie tritt an als fortschritts
bündnis für freiheit gerechtigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit
für das bundesministerium für umwelt
naturschutz
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz beginnt damit ein
neues kapitel 5 kernaufgaben bin ich
hier beschreiben die dieses kapitel
prägen werden erstens dass arten
aussterben ist die zweite große
ökologische krise neben der klimakrise
sie wird und sie muss jetzt stärker ins
zentrum der politik rücken denn es geht
um unsere lebensgrundlagen um wasser
luft zum atmen lebensmittel wer beim
naturschutz an zauneidechsen und
laubfrösche alleine denkt hat das
problem immer noch nicht begriffen
bis zu einer million arten bis zu einer
million arten sind innerhalb der
nächsten jahrzehnte vom aussterben
bedroht sagt uns die wissenschaft diese
arten werden fehlen und zwar in aller
erster linie uns fruchtbare äcker gibt
es nicht ohne biologische vielfalt
sauerstoff nicht ohne intakte ohne das
intakte ökosysteme pflanzen brauchen
bestäuber hochwasserschutz braucht auch
in klimaschutz braucht moore und alte
wälder und zwar hier und weltweit
es geht jetzt deshalb darum nach
jahrzehnten der naturzerstörung ein
zeitalter der renaturierung einzuläuten
es geht darum mit den moorschutz zu
stärken die biologische vielfalt dem
wasserhaushalt meeresschutz ist
klimaschutz die neue bundesregierung
wird eine offensive für den meeresschutz
staaten global durch neue schutzzonen
hierzulande durch ein besseres
management der schutzgebiete und eine
verbindliche meeres strategie
wir brauchen eine agrarwende
die den verbraucherschutz die natur und
tierschutz und die wirtschaftsgrundlage
für landwirtinnen und landwirte neu
verbindet die pestizide und nitrat
einträge in die ökosysteme reduziert am
besten was den eintrag in
naturschutzgebiete anbetrifft sehr
schnell gegen null
zweitens
zweitens in diesem neuen kapitel wird
der verbraucherschutz zur zweiten
wichtigen säule neben dem umweltschutz
beide verstärken sich gegenseitig beide
verbessern den alltag der bürgerinnen
und bürger wenn ein fernseher oder eine
waschmaschine entsorgt werden muss nur
weil ein einzelteil kaputt aber nicht
austauschbar ist kostet das verbraucher
sinnlos geld und es verschwendet
rohstoffe oder wenn ein handy nicht mehr
richtig genutzt werden kann nur weil
kein vernünftiges update mehr zur
verfügung steht die bundesregierung
plant ein recht auf reparatur und sie
wird anreize dafür schaffen langlebige
produkte herzustellen die
erstellung von it geräten willich
verpflichten updates und ersatzteile zur
verfügung zu stellen mindestens für die
übliche nutzungsdauer eines produkts
drittens
kreislaufwirtschaft die enge verknüpfung
von umwelt und verbraucherschutz zeigt
sich auch bei der dritten kernaufgabe
die im ressourcenschutz durch
kreislaufwirtschaft plastiktüten und
einweg teller aus plastik werden bald
geschichte sein es ist ein guter aber
nur ein erster schritt das
problembewusstsein wächst aber
gleichzeitig wachsen noch immer die
plastik berger und deshalb geht es in
deutschland darum einerseits plastikmüll
zu reduzieren und andererseits den rest
in hoher qualität zu recyceln erst dann
entsteht ein kreislauf ich werde auf
europäischer ebene höhere
recyclingquoten für einen verbindlichen
anteil von 30 grad in verpackungen und
einheitliche standards für recyceltes
plastik eintreten und dies vorantreiben
international müssen wir endlich zu
einem wirksamen abkommen zur reduktion
von plastikmüll kommen bevor in den
meeren in den weltmeeren noch mehr davon
schwimmt und niemand braucht micro
plastik im gesichts- oder zahncremes
eigentlich eine alte diskussion die
längst hätte erledigt sein können ich
will dass wir europaweit micro plastik
in kosmetika und waschmittel endlich
ausschließen und wenn es nicht anders
geht durch ein verbot
viertels atomausstieg die gürtel
kernaufgabe des ministeriums wird der
abschluss des atomausstiegs seien die
entscheidung zum ausstieg wurde und wird
von einer übergroßen mehrheit in unserem
land getragen die argumente sind
zahlreich vom uranbergbau über die
risiken in betrieb ist zur ungeklärten
haftungsfragen die atomkraft ist eine
hochrisikotechnologie sie wird nicht
ausreichend versichert sie ist extrem
teuer und sie kommt ohne staatliche
garantien nicht aus daran ändern auch
die märchen und mythen über neue
reaktoren nicht und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der cdu csu
was ihre außenpolitiker hier irgend
gerade zur taxen und mia zählt scheinbar
mehr als scheinheilig es ist
bundeskanzlerin merkel gewesen die diese
debatte so lange hat laufen lassen und
deutschland wird seine position jetzt
natürlich klar machen wenn binnenmarkt
kommissar der eu binnenmarktkommissar
ankündigt das 550 milliarden für die
atomkraft in europa notwendig sein
werden bei gleichzeitig sinkt im anteil
an der stromerzeugung dann muss
deutschland diese diskussion offensiv
führen damit öffentliche gelder nicht in
diese
diese und wir werden das tun und
trotzdem das deutsch französische
verhältnis pflegen und die
präsidentschaft unterstützen die
französische die fünfte kernaufgabe
klimaschutz im neuen kapitel der
umweltpolitik ist diese aufgabe endlich
da angekommen wo sie hingehört überall
in der wirtschaft im verkehr im bauwesen
in der landwirtschaft wird klimaschutz
in zukunft verortet sein und natürlich
bleibt auch das umweltministerium
klimaschutz ministerium das bfv
verantwortet die natürlichen klimaschutz
mit einem aktionsprogramm werde ich
naturnahe wälder und moore stärken
kanalisierte flüsse und bäche und ihre
augen sollen renaturiert werden
ökosysteme die kohlenstoff speichern und
gleichzeitig vor dem nächsten hochwasser
schützen die letzten jahre haben gezeigt
mit welcher wucht die klimakrise auch in
deutschland zuschlägt wir werden deshalb
gemeinsam mit ländern und kommunen
bessere vorsorge gegen klimaschäden
treffen sei es starkregen management
schutz vor dürre und hitze renaturierung
mehr grün in städten und auf dächern
eine vorausschauende stadt und
regionalplanung deshalb
deshalb werde ich die förderprogramme
des bundes verstärken um die kommunalen
anpassungsstrategien zu unterstützen ich
werde ein programm auf den weg bringen
um unter anderem die wasserversorgung
und unsere gewässer besser auf die
folgen der klimakrise vorzubereiten und
wir werden ein klima anpassungs gesetz
vorlegen und eine anpassungsstrategie
erarbeiten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
acht minuten sind knapp ist passt nicht
alles in diese räder
lassen sie bitte nicht die ministerin
von etiketten für sie und ihre fraktion
leid und vielleicht auch für den natur-
und klimaschutz
ja ja wir werden mit einer aktiven
umwelt und verbraucherpolitik für mehr
freiheit gerechtigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit sorgen und alle
kolleginnen und kollegen aus den
fraktionen die diese ziele teilen lade
ich als ministerin gerne zur
zusammenarbeit und mitarbeit ein und
freue mich darauf vielen dank
steffi lemke die neue
bundesumweltministerin ja eher vom
erhalt der artenvielfalt über den
meeresschutz über den verbraucherschutz
und vieles was dazu gehört die
kreislaufwirtschaft und die klima
anpassungsstrategie einiges konnte sie
nehmen eher relativ wenig hat sie gesagt
zur aktuellen diskussion rund um den
plänen der eu-kommission in gas und
atomkraftwerke als klimafreundliche
einzustufen denn heute sollte
ursprünglich die frist enden wo die
mitgliedstaaten ihr votum äußern konnten
aber steffi lemke kündigte ein klares
nein an die frist ist ohnehin noch mal
verschoben worden steffen bilger jetzt
für die cdu/csu-fraktion politische
opposition sein aber auch eine
opposition die sie dann unterstützt wenn
von der regierung sinnvolle vorschläge
kommen
auch in der umwelt und
verbraucherpolitik haben wir als
unions-parteien klare maßstäbe was
sinnvolle politik ist um den
bestmöglichen nutzen für mensch umwelt
und natur zu erzielen muss sie
ineinander greifen und möglichst aus
einem guss sein sie muss unideologisch
an die dinge herangehen sie muss
technologie offen und innovativ sein und
sie muss integrieren kompromiss und
ausgleich suchen und darf keinesfalls
spalten
leider habe ich aber nach dem studium
des koalitionsvertrags und wenigen tagen
ihrer amtszeit die befürchtung dass ihre
politik diesem anspruch nicht gerecht
wird lassen sie mich das an einigen
punkten verdeutlichen zunächst müssen
wir schon auch darüber sprechen was sie
etwas verschämt in ihrer rede
angesprochen haben frau bundesministerin
nämlich die weitgehende herauslösung des
klimaschutzes aus dem
bundesumweltministerium sie entkernt ihr
haus denn der klimaschutz ist das
umweltpolitische querschnittsthema und
die verschiebung
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium ist
einzig grüner machtarithmetik geschuldet
statt der erforderlichen bündelung steht
sogar eine weitere fragmentierung zu
befürchten wenn er habe klimapolitik
macht dann muss natürlich auch frau berg
klimapolitik machen dürfen und deshalb
findet sich dann die zuständigkeit für
internationale klimapolitik und die
un-klimakonferenz nun im auswärtigen amt
damit zerschlagen sie willkürlich
gewachsene und bewährte strukturen das
schadet deutschen interessen und es
schadet dem internationalen klimaschutz
wir beobachten war durch die verzwergung
eines einstmals stolzen hauses und das
letztendlich nur aufgrund grüne
befindlichkeiten
beim blick in den koalitionsvertrag ist
festzustellen dass ich zumindest in den
ankündigungen etwas tut beim thema
planungs beschleunigung das sind wir uns
einig wir brauchen in deutschland eine
echte planungs beschleunigung aber nicht
nur für den klimaschutz nicht nur für
die energiewende ist sondern für die
gesamte infrastruktur und im
verkehrsbereich auch nicht nur für die
schiene sondern auch für die
wasserstraße und für die straße denn
moderne verkehrswege entlasten die
menschen von lärm und schlechter luft
ich bin gespannt auf ihr diesbezügliches
engagement auf holland
auch hier werden sie auf europäischer
ebene gefordert sein muss ehrlich sagen
meine bisherige erfahrung mit dem
bundesumweltministerium war immer nur
dass ihr haus steine in den weg gelegt
hat blockiert in brüssel hintertrieben
hat wenn es ein
planungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
der genau beobachten ob sie in brüssel
so agieren wie sie es in berlin in den
koalitionsvertrag geschrieben haben
und ich bin auch gespannt auf die
auseinandersetzung mit den
naturschutzverbänden wenn diese
bundesregierung für die energiewende
beim artenschutz stärker den fokus auf
die pool auf den population statt wenn
auf den schutz des einzelnen tieres
legen wird das macht grundsätzlich sinn
nur würde ich mir dann auch wünschen
dass dieses umdenken nicht an der
nächsten windkraftanlage enden würde
beispiel wolf für einen wirksamen schutz
der weite tierhaltung und auch des
menschen vor dem wolf wäre dieser
population einsatz genau der richtige
weg
[Applaus]
vernünftig und unideologisch muss sich
deutschland auf europäischer ebene
einbringen stichwort taxonomie auch ich
sehen der kernenergie und den gas keine
nachhaltige front energieversorgung aber
die bundesregierung darf nicht den rest
europas gegen unser land aufbringen
klimaschutz in europa ist eine
gemeinsame aufgabe aber die wege zur
zielerreichung können unterschiedlich
sein und dies ist sollten sie nicht
anderen vorschreiben wollen frau
bundesministerin mit dem umwelt und
verbraucherschutz verantworten sie
themenbereiche die tief in das
alltägliche leben der menschen in
deutschland eingreifen um so wichtiger
ist es dass sie ein verbindender
kooperative ansatz leitet wenn ich mir
mal so die diskussion innerhalb ihrer
koalition in den letzten tagen anschauen
kritik von der fdp zu elektrischen
zahnbürste zu pestizid vorschlägen
ihrerseits weiß ich nicht ob in der
koalition schon wirklich so viel
kooperative ansatz festzustellen ist
aber noch mal ein verbindender
kooperative ansatz ist wichtig und sie
und ihr kollege özdemir werden beim
erhalt der biodiversität nicht
vorankommen wenn sie wieder und wieder
das viel zu einfache feindbild eine
profit maximieren und umwelt vergessen
den landwirtschafts zeichnen sie 100
graben die akzeptanz des umweltschutz
ist auch wenn es in brüssel
stillschweigend wenn von ihren
parteifreunden im europaparlament
realitätsfremde grenzwerte beschlossen
werden sollen die der individuellen
mobilität den boden entziehen und einmal
mehr die im stich gelassen werden die
auf ihr auto angewiesen sind und
sicherheit keinen neuwagen leisten
können
und damit meine damen und herren wir
beides sozialen dimensionen ihre politik
sie schaden dem umwelt- ressourcen- und
klimaschutz wenn sie unterschlagen dass
steigende energiepreise enorm sozialen
sprengstoff bergen dazu haben sie in
ihrer rede gar nichts gesagt als
verbraucherschutzministerin sind sie
gefordert auf den sozialen ausgleich zu
achten es drängt sich der eindruck auf
dass ihre regierung noch nicht bewusst
ist wie groß die auswirkungen ihrer
politik auf den geldbeutel der
verbraucher sein werden mein fazit
es ist überaus gefährlich wenn des
bundesumwelt und jetzt ja
verbraucherschutzministerium und
ideologische nicht innovative ansätze
und aktionismus vom verlust der
zentralen zuständigkeit für den
klimaschutz ablenken will wir werden auf
jeden fall streng aufpassen dass dies
nicht zum schaden der bürgerinnen und
bürger der wirtschaft und letztendlich
der umwelt wegen mangelnder akzeptanz
ihrer politik geschieht
hier steffen bilger der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
fraktion und
zum ressort umwelt natur schon zu sein
erkläre sicherheit und verbraucherschutz
hat jetzt kassel träger für die spd das
wort er sprecher für umwelt naturschutz
nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz genau also das ressort
präsidentin kollegen und kollegen liebe
umwelt und verbraucherschutz ministerin
steffi lemke vielen dank für engagierte
rede für die kraftvollen linien diese
gezeichnet haben von dem bild der
umweltpolitik die wir in den nächsten
vier jahren gemeinsam gestalten wollen
wir freuen uns auf diese zusammenarbeit
und endlich geht's los
wir unterstützen ausdrücklich
die idee von dem sozial ökologischen
umbau unserer wirtschaft unserer
gesellschaft von der art und weise wie
wir leben und arbeiten
[Musik]
auch wenn es mit großen
herausforderungen die wir nicht
übersehen wollen für menschen verbunden
ist für den naturschutz landwirtschaft
für industrie und mittelstand für
letztlich jede und jeden von uns aber
wir sagen eben ja zu einem
ambitionierten klimaschutz wir wollen
bis 2045 klimaneutral werden wir wollen
bis 2030 80 prozent unseres
stromverbrauchs regenerativ decken und
dazu gehen wir eben konsequent den weg
des ausbaus der neue erneuerbaren
energien und weil es vorhin angesprochen
würde wir sagen nein zu einem weiter bei
der atomenergie und wie kraftvoll die
afg ihr argument vertritt sieht man ja
an der regen beteiligung an dieser
debatte gerade mal vier sind da aber
immerhin wir auf jeden fall wollen dass
die erneuerbaren energien in zukunft die
tragende säule sind für unseren zur
deckung unseres strombedarfs und da muss
auch mein heimatland bayern bei der
windkraft weiter springen wir wollen
dass die 10h regel perspektive feld
und sozialdemokraten ist aber auch klar
dass wir diesen weg der transformation
mit den menschen gemeinsam gehen wollen
und müssen wir sehen große echte chancen
für wirtschaft arbeit und wohlstand wenn
deutschland an der spitze der
entwicklung steht aber über die großen
ziele im horizont darf man eben nicht
die kurze wegstrecke die wir unmittelbar
vor den füßen haben übersehen denn sonst
werden wir stolpern und dazu frau
ministerin reichen wir ihnen gerne die
hand dass das nicht passiert wir sie
können sich in der zusammenarbeit darauf
verlassen dass wir das soziale im blick
haben werden darauf können sich die
menschen in deutschland verlassen
und lieber kollege bilder bilder auch
wenn die zentrale zuständigkeit für den
klimaschutz innerhalb der
bundesregierung und des parlaments in
ein nachbar ressort gewandert ist so ist
klimaschutz doch eine umfassende aufgabe
für alle politikfelder und
selbstverständlich für uns
umweltschützer ganz voran es ist keine
vertagung sondern ist ein tribut an die
gewachsene bedeutung von klimaschutz
geben viel mehr umfasst als nur das
umweltressort
und gerade der neue bereich des
natürlichen klimaschutzes bringt uns in
die verantwortung die natürlichen
verbündeten im kampf gegen den
klimawandel
moore wälder feuchtgebiete aber auch
seegraswiesen zu aktivieren zu schützen
und zu stärken und das wollen wir
gemeinsam gerne tun
und gleichzeitig müssen wir die zweite
große krise dieses planeten das globale
artensterben bekämpfen und überwinden
und wie ist es wahr wir haben bereits
schöne erfolge im naturschutz erreicht
aber dennoch ist die lage insgesamt
genauso bedrohlich wie beim klimawandel
aber es ist noch nicht zu spät und
deshalb bin ich froh
dass sie auch dieses thema einen
schwerpunkt setzen wollen genauso wie es
ihre amtsvorgängerin svenja schulze
übrigens auch getan hat mit der
verabschiedung des insektenschutz
gesetzes war eine schwere geburt und
dafür dann noch mal herzlichen dank
nachträglich an svenja schulze und wir
sozialdemokraten stehen gerne zur
verfügung bei diesem kampf gegen das
artensterben
wir wollen ja gerne weiter gemeinsam
voran schreiten und drittens
müssen wir uns damit beschäftigen wie
wir die menschen vor den folgen des
klimawandels schützen der bereits
begonnen hat und der auch in deutschland
zu spüren ist die ereignisse dieses
sommers in rheinland pfalz in nordrhein
westfalen aber auch in bayern haben uns
das wieder mal schmerzlich vor augen
geführt und natürlich gab es auch schon
vorher ansetzen und bemühungen beim
hochwasserschutz zum beispiel aber es
gab eben bisher keine zentrale steuerung
für die vorsorge nun wird es einen
klaren rechtsrahmen geben sie haben es
genannt es wird eine klima
anpassungsstrategie geben und wir haben
uns sehr dafür eingesetzt und sind
dankbar dass es gelungen ist dass wir
ein klima anpassungs gesetz gemeinsam
schaffen werden für die hitze versorge
für die gesundheitsvorsorge für wasser-
infrastruktur- und vieles mehr nicht
umsonst haben wir viel lob von den
umweltverbänden für all das gibt
bekommen dass wir uns im
koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen haben ich habe leider keine
zeit mehr um auf das weite feld
verbraucherschutz einzugehen aber ich
will mal sagen es gibt viel zu tun ich
bin sehr zuversichtlich dass wir
erfolgreich sehen sein werden hatten wir
es an vielen dank
er teile das wort dem abgeordneten
andreas plecko auf die fraktion
[Applaus]
hatte frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen
und kollegen werter herr kollege träger
ich bin überhaupt nicht verwundert vor
allem weil ich weiß dass sie wider
besseres wissen sprechen sie wissen ganz
genau dass ihre undemokratischen
maßnahmen eben dazu führen dass eben
nicht alle abgeordneten teilnehmen
können die gerne teilnehmen würden in
der europäischen union ist die
bundesregierung wieder einmal der
geisterfahrer sie lehnt die aufnahme der
kernenergie in die taxonomie ab und das
obwohl sie sowohl co2 arm als auch
grundlastfähig ist sie ist also die
antwort auf die frage wie man
klimaschutz und versorgungssicherheit in
einklang bringen kann da die grünen das
problem der erneuerbaren energien bei
der versorgungssicherheit nicht
verstehen und sich vize präsidentin
katrin göring eckardt poesie im
deutschen bundestag wünscht versuche ich
dieses problem in einfacher sprache
poetisch am beispiel der windkraft mit
wilhelm busch zu erklären aus der mühle
schaut der müller der so gerne malen
will stiller wird der wind und stille
und die mühle steht still so geht es
immer wie ich finde rief der müller
voller zorn hat man korn so viel sun
winde hat man vinzenz am korn die hatte
kolleginnen und kollegen im unterschied
zum einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert musste
man im neunzehnten jahrhundert das auf
die windkraft nicht ohne weiteres
verlassen ist in deutschland
interessiert sich die bundesregierung
zwar für klima treiber nicht aber für
preistreiber die folge vier prozent
inflation und explodierende strom und
gaspreise mit der eeg-umlage und der co2
abgabe werden die bürger gnadenlos
abkassiert die regierungen
polen und tschechien wollen ihre bürger
mit einer aufhebung oder senkung der
mehrwertsteuer auf strom und gas
entlasten und die bundesregierung
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister camps
definiert währenddessen über höhere
lebensmittelpreise herzlichen
glückwunsch ihre politik gegen die
globale erwärmung ist eine politik der
sozialen kälte
darüber hinaus positioniert sich die
bundesregierung im spannungsfeld
zwischen klimaschutz und artenschutz
völlig einseitig der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien soll im
öffentlichen interesse sein und der
öffentlichen sicherheit dienen habeck
nennt das die energiewende mit
atemschutz versöhnen er verwechselt
offenbar versöhnen und versündigen fakt
ist windkraftanlagen töten jährlich
hunderttausende vögel und fledermäuse
eine fläche die etwa dreimal so groß wie
saarland ist wollen sie mit
windkraftanlagen verspargelung damit
opfern insbesondere die grünen klima
postwendend atemschutz auf dem altar der
energiewende und widerspruch aus dem
bundesumweltministerium gibt es nicht
die pläne der bundesregierung zum ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien sind
gefährlich windkraftanlagen soll näher
an häuser gebaut werden dadurch werden
bewohner durch infraschall stärker
gesundheitlich belastet
windkraftanlagen sollen auch näher andré
funkfeuer gebaut werden dadurch werde
die signale zur orientierung von
flugzeugen stärker gestört sie wehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sie ignorieren
das öffentliche interesse und sie sind
ein sicherheitsrisiko
es ist unfassbar mit welcher
dreistigkeit sie die wirklichkeit
verdrehen doch die größte enttäuschung
der ampelkoalition von ihnen habe ich
nichts anderes erwartet ist aber
tatsächlich die fdp früher forderte sie
unter anderem die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage ein verbot des baus von
windkraftanlagen in wäldern und eine
technologieoffene förderung das haben
die ja mit gutem grund gefordert heute
ist davon aber nichts mehr übrig für die
fdp waren die forderungen bei der
bildung der ampelkoalition
verhandlungsmasse die man jeweils für
vier minister sitze und minister wagen
bereitwillig aufgegeben hat damit nimmt
sich die ampel koalition tatsächlich
eine ampel zum vorbild bei einer ampel
sieht man häufig rot und grün und bei
gelb hält sowieso niemand vielen dank
andreas blick war das für die afg
fraktion und ihm folgt jetzt für die
fdp-fraktion judith skudelny sich die
sprecherin für umwelt und
verbraucherschutz
und die nächste rednerin ist judith
skudelny von der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsidentin meine damen und
herren normalerweise hätte ich mich hier
zurück nicht mit manchen parteien
auseinander zu setzen aber sehr geehrter
herr kollege dessen partei selber
einteilen vom verfassungsschutz
überwacht wird sollte sich dezidiert
zurückhaltend andere leute einem
sicherheitsrisiko zu nehmen
meine damen was in baden württemberg an
der tradierten anhänglichkeit eines
ministerpräsidenten an der cdu
gescheitert es ist uns hier im bund
gelungen wir haben es geschafft ein
sozial ökologisches bündnis der
erneuerung zu schmieden und das freut
mich persönlich das freut unsere
koalition und das wird deutschland
voranbringen
wir haben uns als ampel auf dem
umweltbereich viele und umwelt und
verbraucherschutz viele wichtige themen
auf das zettel geschrieben in meiner
kurzen rede zeit werde ich mich auf drei
themen die mir am herzen liegen die uns
am herzen liegen konzentrieren
in zeiten des bevölkerungswachstums und
in zeiten des klimawandels ist der
erhalt der artenvielfalt eine der
dringendsten und vornehmsten aufgaben
die wir in der umweltpolitik haben die
resilienz die krisenfestigkeit unserer
natur ist ein wichtiges ziel das wir in
dieser legislaturperiode
erreichen müssen hierzu haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag ein umfassendes
maßnahmenpaket vorgelegt und wir haben
es auch finanziell unterlegt damit
werden wir ein umschwung in der arten
krise erreichen was vielen regierungen
vor uns nicht gelungen ist
wichtig wichtig sind aber die
anpassungsstrategien nicht nur die von
natur sondern auch für die menschen die
grausame überschwemmungen im sommer
letzten jahres haben gezeigt dass natur
und mensch durchaus vor den gleichen
herausforderungen stehen deswegen bin
ich froh und stolz dass wir in unserem
umwelt kapitel einen ganz großen bereich
den klima anpassungsmaßnahmen gewidmet
haben die mit kurz und langfristigen
maßnahmen unterlegt haben so dass wir
nicht nur versuchen den klimawandel
abzuhalten sondern auch schon die
eingetretenen folgen des klimawandels im
wege der vorsorge mit ihnen umgehen und
so mensch und natur auch künftig
schützen können
aber nicht alles
was für den menschen gutes ist für die
natur richtig gerade im bereich der
erneuerbaren energien sehen wir dass
punktuelle eingriffe in der natur
notwendig sein können und müssen um die
langfristigen ziele des klimaschutzes zu
erreichen die balance zu finden und zu
halten wird die aufgabe des klima
ministeriums und des umweltministeriums
gemeinsam sein im koalitionsvertrag
haben wir ein schutzprogramm hinterlegt
das diesen ausgleich auch für die
artenvielfalt in deutschland möglich
machen sollen ich bin der überzeugung
dass diese regierung es schaffen wird
das bisherige spannungsfeld aufzulösen
und den beiden themen gemeinsam voran zu
schreiten
eines der wichtigen themen für mich und
1 hat mich besonders stolz macht dass
das thema kreislaufwirtschaft zum ersten
mal wird die kreislaufwirtschaft
wirklich ausgiebig und sehr groß auch im
koalitionsvertrag und im handeln der
ministerin erwähnt was mich freut ist
dass er das kreislaufwirtschaft nicht
nur ein wichtiger baustein zum
klimaschutz ist sondern es ist auch
garant für eine umweltschonende und
sichere rohstoffversorgung in
deutschland viele krisen in der welt von
und politische auseinandersetzung bis
hin zu aktuellen corona krise haben
gezeigt wie abhängig die gesellschaft
wie abhängig die wirtschaft von einer
sicheren rohstoffversorgung ist alle
rohstoffe die in deutschland und europa
zurückgenommen und zurückgewonnen und
recycelt werden können sicher unsere
wirtschaft ab und schaffen umwelt und
klimaschutz gleichzeitig die
kreislaufwirtschaft ist eines der
wichtigsten ziele und wir werden
gemeinsam die schließung dieser
kreisläufe erreichen
was mich besonders freut
ist dass sich die koalition offen
gezeigt hat für neue technologien und
methoden mit dem chemischen recycling
eröffnen wir neue wege mit neuen
technologien das klima schützen kleid
kreisläufe schließen rohstoffe sichern
das ist liberale umweltschutz im besten
sinne und es freut mich dass wir uns in
dieser koalition auch dazu verpflichtet
haben
unsere gemeinsame ziel in der koalition
werden flankiert und begleitet von einer
planungs beschleunigung die wir brauchen
um unsere ziele auch umzusetzen wir
werden es gemeinsam schaffen meine damen
und herren diese koalition ist nicht
liebe auf den ersten blick sie ist
gewachsenes vertrauen sie ist gemeinsame
ziele und sie ist der wille zum
gemeinsamen handeln das wird unsere ehe
auf zeit nicht nur zum erfolg bringen
sondern vielleicht auch die verlängerung
frau ministerin auf unsere unterstützung
könnten sich verlassen
die sagt judith skudelny für die
fdp-fraktion
und man konnte nicht so erkennen unter
der maske ob steffi lemke doch ein wenig
schmunzeln musste
ja klimaanpassung das ist tatsächlich
ein großes ein großer abschnitt in dem
kapitel den koalitionsvertrag judith
skudelny hat das land also die
flutkatastrophe 221 für 2021 die
ein nachdenken darüber nochmal verstärkt
hat dass man vorsorgende klima
anpassungsstrategie machen muss und das
soll in dieser legislatur verstärkt
angegangen werden drive lenkert jetzt
für die linke kolleginnen und kollegen
die neue ampel regierung startet mit
besten vorsätzen für die umwelt und ich
hoffe dass diese vorsätze eine größere
haltbarkeit haben als die vorsätze zum
neuen jahr die linke voller zeit vielen
jahren für technische produkte
garantierte nutzungszeiten und
reparierbar kite zwei jahre
gewährleistung sind nicht genug als
techniker bei sich man kann
waschmaschinen so herstellen dass sie
zehn jahre halten heimelektronik sechs
jahre funktioniert computer schaffen mit
verpflichtenden upgrades für hard und
software diese sechs jahre auch und mit
einem wechselakku sind drei jahre für
smartphones kein wunder
damit solche garantiert nutzungszeiten
wirksam werden fordert dass die linke
das sport teure neue käufe und schont
die umwelt
liebe bürgerinnen und hören sie sollen
bewusst leben sollen umweltbewusst
einkaufen zum schutze ihrer gesundheit
zum schutze der umwelt die industrie
schiebt die verantwortung gerne auf
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher das hat
ein haken ökologische produkte sind oft
euro viele können sie sich nicht leisten
und deshalb fordert die linke höhere
löhne höhere renten und sozialleistungen
damit sich jeder gesunde produkte kaufen
kann
jeder produzent jede händlerin muss
verantwortung übernehmen dass ihre
produkte auch die sozial- und
umweltstandards einhalten
selbstverpflichtung und appelle reichen
bei weitem nicht aus es braucht strenge
gesetzliche vorgaben
die hersteller müssen für schäden haften
die ihre produkte verursachen auch im
abwasser
arzneimittelreste micro plastik
schädigen unsere flüsse sie können mit
neuen kläranlagen mit der nachrüstung
entfernt werden aber die
abwassergebühren würden sich verdoppeln
unbezahlbar für viele mieterinnen und
mieter und menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen deshalb fordern wir dass
hersteller die wasser schädliche
produkte herstellen die kosten für die
nachrüstung der klärwerke übernehmen
müssen so geht sozial gerechte
umweltschonende produktverantwortung
kolleginnen und kollegen es gibt viele
umweltschäden die entschlossenes handeln
auffordern zum schutz des rosses fordern
wir beispielsweise die einrichtung von
total schutzzonen und ein verbot der
schleppnetzfischerei und
selbstverständlich eine entschädigung
für die fischereibetriebe für die
entgangenen einnahmen
wir unterstützen die ministerin beim
verzicht auf den ausbau von elbe und
oder das geld ist sinnvoller eingesetzt
in die renaturierung der flüsse in den
rückbau von querbau werden dass freud in
lachs den alt die forelle den fluss
fischer und die anderen
halbposition aus zwei weltkriegen
gefährdet menschen und wälder
wir fordern dass der bund endlich sich
an der beseitigung dieser alte munition
beseitigt egal ob sie aus deutschen oder
alliierten beständen stammt
und unsere welt sie leiden unter den
temperaturanstieg unter den dirnen wie
acht 2018 2019 und 20 unterstützung und
schädlingsbefall
staatliche kommunale aber auch private
waldbesitzer schaffen den notwendigen
waldumbau ohne hilfe nicht schnell genug
deswegen ist ein weit rettungsprogramm
unerlässlich mit geldern für
grundlagenforschung mit wir wissen
welche baumarten in welchen gebieten
zukünftig überleben wir brauchen geld um
für mehr baumschulen damit ausreichend
setzlinge für den waldumbau bereitstehen
und wir brauchen geld für mehr frust
arbeiterin und waldarbeitern mit guten
löhnen frau ministerin bei der umsetzung
solcher punkte haben sie unsere
unterstützung
und liebe bürgerinnen und bürger die
linke steht für konsequente
friedenspolitik kriege sind eine
humanitäre katastrophe aber eben auch
die sinnloseste umweltzerstörung
deswegen ist unser nein zu
auslandseinsätzen und
ein verbot von rüstungsexporten
auch umweltschutz vielen dank
sagt hier rein benkert für die linke ist
[Applaus]
der aussprache in der aussprache ressort
umwelt und verbraucherschutz so in der
stefan wenzel für die grünen ist er
sprecher für umweltschutz
umwelt und naturschutz verteilt der
geehrte frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen kollegen abgeordnete sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich freue mich
sehr dass wir eine ministerin im
umweltministerium haben die wirklich mit
herzblut an dieser großen aufgaben
herangeht
die frau ministerin haben zu beginn auf
zwei zentrale herausforderungen
verwiesen den klimaschutz und den
artenschutz beide auf augenhöhe
das ist die dimension des problems vor
der wir stehen fehlen die insekten
empfehlen auch baulich vögel und dann
fehlen auch bei die fische und dann
zerreißt es auch die nahrungskette
nahrungskette von der wir leben die
ozeane meine damen und herren sind
gigantische co2 und wärme senken aber
das hat grenzen und das birgt große
gefahren wenn die versauerung und die
erwärmung lebewesen im meer bedrohen und
wir wissen wie viele milliarden menschen
auf der erde sich von meeresfrüchten
ernähren die böden sind unterschätzt in
ihrer bedeutung
auch in bezug auf insekten und
bodenlebewesen der klimaschutz ist auch
artenschutz das ist ein ganz wichtiger
satz das werden wir noch sehen in den
debatten der nächsten monate
ist sie mich eine zweite bemerkung
machen zu den punkten die die ministerin
angesprochen hat
verbraucherschutz
verbraucherschutz schützt den einzelnen
in der ganzen bandbreite
von mir geht medizin bis zu digitalen
diensten leistung vor schlechten
produkten und minderwertigen produkten
es schafft faire preise und transparente
preise und es dient am ende auch
mittelstand und handwerk weil hier
märkte entstehen die transparenz ist da
freue ich mich auf diese neue
herausforderung
lassen sie mich noch ein paar worte zur
taxonomie
ansprechen auch da haben sie deutliche
worte gefunden und ich sage ihnen ganz
deutlich wir brauchen keinen ort welchen
neusprech für alt technologien keine
irreführung von sparkassenkunden und von
investoren die ihr geld gut anlegen
wollen die haftungsfrage das ist nur
eine von mehreren punkten die dem duo
signifikant haben kriterium der agenda
2030 der vereinten nationen
widersprechen aber sie zeigt auf einen
blick dass keine versicherung der welt
heute die risiken in die bücher nehmen
wollte die durch atomkraftwerke
entstehen
und wir wollen vor allen dingen hier
keine neuen wettbewerbsverzerrungen
verzerrungen in einer solch gigantischen
größenordnung öffentliches geld meine
damen und herren muss dort investiert
werden wo es maximal zu vernetzen ist
und wer was kaputt macht der muss auch
zahlen oder die finger davon lassen das
nennt man
verursacherprinzip und
ersten müssen wir auch die gefahr von
waffenfähigem material wenn das über die
ganze welt verbreitet wird einige denken
offenbar dass man kleine schnelle brüter
in vielen ländern der erde verkaufen
können kommen sie bitte den schluss
wegen der neue abhängigkeiten schafft
und ich komme zum letzten satz frau
präsidentin weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht uns eine
wunderbare vorlage gemacht hat im märz
nämlich das urteil ist eine gute
grundlage um die freiheit künftiger
generationen auf der basis einer sozial
ökologischen transformation zu sichern
ich danke ihnen herr
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das wort 4 und simon
kollegen führen simon cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen kollegen die damen und
herren es
war der 29 juli 2021 an diesem tag hatte
die weltbevölkerung bereits an den
nachhaltig nutzbaren ressourcen für das
gesamte vergangene jahr verbraucht wir
alle kennen diesen sogenannten derart
überlastung tag die weltweite nachfrage
an ressourcen übersteigt das angebot
welches unserer erde selbst erneuern
kann bereits seit jahrzehnten
wir müssen und wir wollen diesen
weltweit vorherrschenden probleme
weiterhin entschlossen entgegentreten
deswegen nimmt die kreislaufwirtschaft
spätestens seit ihrer aufnahme in die
nationale gesetzgebung durch die union
mit umweltminister klaus töpfer im jahr
1994 eine zentrale rolle in unserer
umwelt politik ein
[Applaus]
effizienter einsatz von ressourcen und
das schließen von stoffkreisläufen ist
jedoch nicht nur ein geeignetes mittel
um der ressourcenknappheit
entgegenzutreten vielmehr ist eine
funktionierende kreislaufwirtschaft ein
wesentlicher bestandteil des
klimaschutzes in deutschland und leistet
einen wesentlichen beitrag für eine
prosperierende wirtschaft schafft
arbeitsplätze und sichert den wohlstand
in unserem land wir können in
deutschland auf eine erfolgreiche
politik in den vergangenen jahren
zurückblickt und müssen uns mit unseren
erfolgen im internationalen vergleich
nicht verstecken
und wenn ich dann von seiten der spd
hören am heutigen tag in diesem plenum
dass es jetzt endlich losgeht dann
möchte ich doch am 08 12 2021 zurück
erinnern bis zu dem tag hat die spd
nämlich die vorgängerin der heutigen
welt ministerin gestellt
herr deutschland wird mit einer
hervorragenden entwickelt eine
kreislaufwirtschaft weltweit schon heute
eine vorreiterrolle ein in kaum einem
anderen land werden an die 100 prozent
aller abfälle flächendeckend erfasst so
existieren es ist es existieren in
deutschland und
15.500 entsorgungsanlagen zum vergleich
die zahl der gemeinden in deutschland
liegt bei knapp 11.000 davon sind 2054
städte das heißt jede stadt verfügt im
schnitt über siebeneinhalb anlagen pro
stadt beim hausmüll wurden zuletzt 64
prozent einem recycling zugeführt 79
prozent des gesamten abfalls wurden
verwertet bereits 14 prozent der für die
wirtschaften notwendigen rohstoffe
wurden aus abfällen gewonnen entsorgungs
technologien made in germany sind ein
exportschlager und wir wollen dass das
so bleibt 25 prozent des weltmarktes für
entsorgungstechnik stammt aus
deutschland in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode haben wir mit einer
vielzahl von gesetzesinitiativen und
novellen die kreislaufwirtschaft in
deutschland maßgeblich weiterentwickelt
dazu gehören beispielsweise das
kreislaufwirtschaftsgesetz das elektro
und elektronikgerätegesetz das
verpackungs gesetz die einweg kunststoff
verbots verordnung die klärschlamm
verordnung die gewerbeabfall verordnung
oder die ersatz baustoff verordnung mit
diesen gesetzen und verordnungen haben
wir als union in den vergangenen
legislaturperioden
wichtige impulse gesetzt
jahren anspruchsvolle aber vor allem
auch wirksame vorgaben für die
rückgewinnung von rohstoffen und der
schließung von stoffkreisläufen
verabschiedet und eingesetzt sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
sie diesen erfolgreichen weg in den
kommenden jahren fort würden fortführen
wollen haben sie uns in ihrer seite der
politische rahmen für die
kreislaufwirtschaft muss künftig
weiterhin gestärkt werden und das
innovationsfreundliches klima das wir in
den vergangenen jahren aufgebaut haben
und uns zum exportweltmeister in sachen
entsorgungs und recycling techniken
gemacht hat muss zwingend erhalten
bleiben und das chemische recycling
steht hier an einem wichtigen punkt und
spielt eine überaus wichtige rolle in
diesem zusammenhang fordern wir die neue
bundesregierung und die ampel koalition
auf auch zukünftige entscheidungen
bereich der kreislaufwirtschaft auch in
der gesamten umweltpolitik immer
faktenbasiert zu treffen eine reihe von
ideologie gesteuerte politik ist hier
fehl am platze nur so kann eine
konsistente nachhaltige und vor allem
und ökologisch sinnvolle politik
ausgestaltet werden darauf werden wir
auch in zukunft in der union gesorgt
haben sie bis zum schluss und die arbeit
sowohl der bundesregierung als auch im
parlamentarischen verfahren kritisch
aber vor allem konstruktiv begleiten
vielen dank
werden sie wurden war das für die cdu
csu fraktion und die kreislaufwirtschaft
spielt auch bei der ampel koalition im
koalitionsvertrag
eine rolle produkte müssen langlebig und
wieder verwendbar sein und die ampel
koalition will sich für eine effektive
kreislaufwirtschaft einsetzen retouren
vernichtung beispielsweise reduzieren
und noch anderes
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte frau bundesministerin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
als ich im herbst 1989 in leipzig anfing
zu studieren
da hatte ich nicht den gedanken dass wir
irgendwann die chance gegeben wird hier
als
bundestagsabgeordnete zu sprechen es ist
mir eine große ehre und eine große
freude hier meine erste rede halten zu
dürfen
mit der wiedervereinigung stießen nicht
nur ganz unterschiedliche
gesellschaftsstrukturen aufeinander
sondern auch völlig unterschiedliche
strukturen in landwirtschaft und umwelt
und gerade die nutzung der flächen wird
jetzt zunehmend gegenstand der
diskussion und führt zu flächen
konkurrenzen da ist zunächst die
landwirtschaft die idealerweise auf
unten bilden hochwertige lebensmittel
erzeugt durch ökonomische zwänge ist
hier leider einiges in schieflage
geraten aber auch umwelt und naturschutz
sind zu beachten durch die ausweisung
unterschiedlichster schutzgebiete soll
eine vielfältige flora und fauna
erhalten und wieder aufgebaut werden den
gewässerschutz und die luftreinhaltung
nehmen wir ernst und
selbstverständlich werden wir auch das
drängendste problem für das drängendste
problem flächen benötigt für den
klimaschutz für die renaturierung von
mooren als kohlenstoffsenken und den
ausbau erneuerbarer energien
laut einer aktuellen studie können 36
prozent der fläche deutschlands ohne
größere konflikte mit dem naturschutz
für windkraft zur verfügung gestellt
werden wie schaffen wir es nur diese
unterschiedlichen interessen in
ausgleich zu bringen der allen gerecht
wird und diesmal wirklich blühende
landschaften und gerät
generationengerechtigkeit zu schaffen
die spd ist angetreten diese konflikte
zu lösen und damit beginnen wir jetzt
und nicht erst in drei jahren
[Musik]
meine bisheriges berufsleben habe ich in
der exekutive verbracht in den
vergangenen jahren war ich
vizepräsidentin dem umweltbundesamt und
referatsleiterin im umweltministerium
schönen gruß an herrn bürger
es ist mir im namen meiner tätigkeit
immer wieder deutlich geworden um die
drängenden probleme im umwelt und
klimaschutz dauerhaft lösen zu können
brauchen wir ein effizientes
zusammenwirken von politik und
verwaltung und müssen dabei alle
beteiligten rechtzeitig einbinden wir
werden den natürlichen klimaschutz
deutlich stärken dieses steht nicht nur
im koalitionsvertrag sondern wird uns
auch gelingen wenn wir die synergien
zwischen natur und klimaschutz
intensiver nutzen
renaturierungs programme müssten
ausgebaut werden wir wollen noch eine
bessere kooperation der
unterschiedlichen flächen nutzer ein
beispiel für eine effiziente
flächennutzung ist die ag photovoltaik
besonders kleinteilige flächen kann man
auf diese weise landwirtschaftliche
nutzung mit der erzeugung erneuerbarer
energien in einklang gebracht werden
hier wollen wir sehr stark voran kommen
wir werden auch den wald klima resistent
weiterentwickeln und seine leistungen
für klimaschutz und biodiversität
angemessen honorieren
hierzu müssen wir die
nachhaltigkeitsstrategien verbindlicher
gestalten
konkretes regierungshandelns gefragt und
auch die parlamentarischen
beteiligungsrechte müssen gestärkt
werden
entscheidend für den erfolg unserer
anstrengungen wird eine enge
zusammenarbeit zwischen den ressorts
seien hier sind wir auf einem guten weg
war wie gestern unser
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck sagte
wir müssen schneller werden
notwendig ist eine enge abstimmung der
unterschiedlichen verwaltungsebenen und
auch externen sachverstand sollten wir
nutzen um unser ziel des nachhaltigen
interessenausgleichs zu erreichen ich
denke an die exzellent aufgestellte
wissenschaft in unserem land in vier
jahren wollen wir zu einer klaren
struktur in der flächennutzung kommen
die gleichzeitig die erzeugung
hochwertiger lebensmitteln zu
angemessenen preisen die förderung der
biodiversität den schutz von boden
wasser und luft sowie die erzeugung
erneuerbarer energien als entscheidenden
beitrag zum klimaschutz ermöglichen
meine meine enkeltochter ist jetzt
sieben monate alt wenn sie mich in 20
jahren fragt was habt ihr getan um eine
lebenswerte umwelt zu erhalten dann will
ich sagen wir haben es angepackt und
zwar gemeinsam
unterwegs applaus aus der eigenen
fraktion und auch von den
koalitionspartnern für die erste rede
von franziska kersten für die spd
fraktion
für die afg fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe zuschauer meine
damen und herren der regierungsparteien
nie zuvor ist der geplante und
willentlich herbeigeführt niedergang
einer industrienationen inso blumigen
worten beschrieben worden wie in dem
vorliegenden koalitionsvertrag sie
sprechen von transformation von
innovation und dekarbonisierung
tatsächlich ist es aber ein manifest der
planwirtschaft und der direkte weg in
die deindustrialisierung
sie begründen das mit der scheinbar
notwendigen rettung des weltklimas von
dem sie scheinbar glauben sie könnten es
direkt von der regierungsbank hier in
berlin maßgeblich beeinflussen aber
genau das können sie eben leider nicht
meine damen und herren am ende ihres
umwelt und klimapolitischen amoklaufs
wird deshalb nur eins stehen
industriestandort deutschland geschwächt
automobilindustrie ruiniert
arbeitslosigkeit auf höchststand
merklicher wohlstandsverlust für alle
und zerstörung großer teile unserer
natur landschaft schon jetzt haben wir
etwa
30.000 windkraftanlagen und sie wollen
diese zahl nun also vervierfachen was
das für das landschaftsbild unserer
naturlandschaften für insekten für den
artenschutz zum teil gefährlicher
greifvögel bedeutet das kann sich wohl
jeder ausmalen
das gigantische recycling problem
ausgedienter rotorblätter komplett
ungelöst früher wollten die grünen die
umwelt von den menschen retten mein
eindruck ist heute müssen wir die umwelt
vor den grünen retten dies alles sind
die folgen einer von jeder realität
befreiten debatte sie befassen sich
damit wie wir den jährlichen co2 ausstoß
deutscher automobile in kürzester zeit
um 60 megatonnen fall werden können das
sind 7 ein tausendstel der chinesischen
jahres emission und dafür sind sie
bereit die weltweit beste sauberste und
ausgereifteste motorentechnologie
abzuwickeln
transformation heißt in diesem falle
demontage unserer wichtigsten
schlüsselindustrie meine damen und
herren und diese transformation ist eine
die weg führen soll von privater
mobilität weg führt von privatem
eigentum und weg führt von der freiheit
des einzelnen sie erzeugt die höchsten
energiepreise in ganz europa menschen
die sich strom oder eine warme wohnung
einfach nicht mehr leisten können und
wie soll dieses problem gelöst werden na
klar durch erhöhen der
transferleistungen heißt die zeche dafür
zahlen die die sie immer zahlen nämlich
die mittelschicht die arbeitenden
menschen ja meine damen und herren die
marxisten von gestern wollten eine
umverteilung von reich zu arm über
diesen punkt sind sie längst hinaus sie
verteilen inzwischen um vorwiegend von
denen die arbeiten zu denen die nicht
arbeiten aber es gibt hoffnung denn
sozialistische träume und utopien enden
in der regel dann wenn das geld
ausgegeben ist welches andere verdient
haben vielen dank
hermann sie haben im
rahmen ihrer rede bezug auf die
umweltpolitik das wort amoklauf in den
mund genommen das ist nicht unsere ort
gebraucht hier im hohen hause und ich
bitte sie in zukunft darauf zu
verzichten
ich erteile das wort zu seiner ersten
rede herrn muhammad al hanak fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren es ist
eine große ehre für mich heute hier zu
stehen nicht nur weil ich als
abgeordneter hier heute meine erste rede
halten darf sondern auch weil ich stolz
bürger eines landes zu sein das vor 20
jahren einen jungen aus dem irak so
herzlich aufgenommen hat ein land das
mich begleitet und mir unabhängig von
der herkunft alle chancen geboten hat
ein land das heute meine heimat ist
deswegen bin ich stolz als mitbürger
unmöglich dieses hohen hauses heute zu
ihnen zu sprechen und zwar für eine
koalition die die menschen egal welcher
herkunft in den mittelpunkt stellt für
eine koalition die endlich nicht mehr
nur die komfortzone verwaltet sondern
für eine koalition die den mut die
vision vor augen hat soziale
marktwirtschaft nachhaltigkeit und
freiheit zusammen zu denken
für den verbraucherschutz heißt das
klare und verständliche regeln für
wirtschaft und konsumenten
nachhaltigkeit als design challenge für
dienstleistungen und produkte freiheit
für markt und mündiger bürger denn wir
brauchen nicht immer nur neue regeln was
wir brauchen sind klare regeln die auch
tatsächlich durchgesetzt werden
und diese klaren regeln müssen
innovations- sicherheit für unternehmen
genauso wie sicherheit und schutz für
verbraucher bedeuten aber hier mangelt
es bislang denn wo kein kläger da kein
richter das meine damen und herren darf
hier nicht länger sein deswegen werden
wir dafür sorgen dass verbraucher in
zukunft möglich automatisch entschädigt
werden wenn der flug oder die bahn zu
spät sind deswegen werden wir auch die
bundesbehörden stärken die für die
kontrolle und verfolgung von verstößen
zuständig sind wenn wir dann noch die
abläufe in den behörden digitalisieren
um vereinfachen dann haben wir eine
bessere zuverlässiger und zukunftsfester
infrastruktur und verbraucherschutz und
das kommt allen zugute meine damen und
herren
das gilt auch für die nachhaltigkeit
nachhaltigkeit zusammenhalt und
individueller freiheit sind keine gegner
sie sind unser gemeinsamer auftrag und
voller chancen deswegen hatten wir es
auch hier wir wollen ein recht auf
reparatur einführen damit wertvolle
rohstoffe nicht weggeschmissen sondern
wieder benutzt werden
wir wollen höchstmögliche nachhaltigkeit
als reseller für produkte so werden
nachhaltigkeit und in ruhe
innovationskraft der wirtschaft
entfesselt
vor allem aber wollen wir auch die
bürgerinnen und bürger stärker deswegen
bauen wir die verbraucherbildung aus wir
stärken die verbraucherzentralen und die
stiftung warentest denn unabhängiger und
niedrigschwelliger informationen sind
unverzichtbar für freie kunden
entscheidungen das meine damen und
herren es zukunftsfester politik das ist
der dreiklang aus klaren regeln
nachhaltigkeit und individueller
freiheit verdient dieser regierung steht
meine damen und herren ich komme zum
schluss meine eltern sind damals aus
einem staat geflogen der weder die
bürger noch die das leben seiner bürger
geschützt hat und die verbraucher schon
gar nicht die nächsten vier jahre hier
als mitglied des deutschen bundestages
etwas zurückzugeben erfüllt mich mit
demut und darf in einer gesellschaft zu
leben indem wir mit worten streiten
erfüllt mich mit stolz es ist unser
ungeheures glück
in diesem sinne freue ich mich auf den
streit in der sache und auf die gute
zusammenarbeit zwischen mitbürgern
vielen vielen dank
das forum hat alle halak für die fdp
fraktion mit seiner ersten rede und er
hat hier
vor allem das war eine punktlandung
augenschein genommen was die ampel für
verbraucher plant und bekommt noch ein
lob von der bundestags vizepräsidentin
weil er sehr gut in der redezeit
geblieben ist das auch immer wichtig
hier also recht auf reparatur verbot von
no show klauseln bei den
fluggesellschaften unter anderem das hat
sich hier die ampel koalition in sachen
verbraucherschutz vorgenommen
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren zum geschäftsbereich
des
bundesumweltministeriums gehört seit
dieser wahlperiode auch der
verbraucherschutz das ist neu und eine
beachtliche und herausfordernde aufgabe
für dich ganz besonders innen frau
ministerin viel erfolg und gutes
gelingen wünsche der verbraucherschutz
betrifft die menschen in ihrem
alltäglichen leben deswegen ist es hier
wichtig dass es regeln gibt die die
menschen in ihrem alltäglichen leben
auch begleitet und diese regeln müssen
auch vom bundestag sachgerecht getroffen
werden und vor dem hintergrund muss
sichergestellt sein dass die kooperation
mit dem bundesjustizministerium
funktioniert ihnen obliegt nach der
geschäftsverteilung der bundesregierung
der verbraucher rechtsschutz und deren
rechtliche durchsetzung dazu braucht man
aber auch die instrumente von bgb und zb
also abteilungen die im
bundesjustizministerium angesiedelt sind
deswegen ist das wichtig dass diese
zusammenarbeit klappt weil große
aufgaben auf uns warten nicht nur das
recht auf reparatur sondern auch die
frage der fortentwicklung der muster
feststellungsklage zu einer sammelklage
damit verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
davon zu recht profitieren ein thema
dass die menschen im augenblick umtreibt
ist natürlich die steigerung der
energiepreise das hat zum einen eine
soziale dimension aber auch eine
rechtliche die akzeptanz der
energiewende wird nur gelingen wenn
energie wenn heizkosten wenn stromkosten
bezahlbar bleiben deswegen brauchen
menschen mit geringem einkommen einen
entsprechenden zuschuss der muss schnell
und in einer richtigen umfang auf den
weg gebracht werden aber wir brauchen
bei dem thema auch mehr regulierung es
kann nämlich nicht sein dass manche
strom oder gaskunden erst durch das
schreiben des grundversorgers erfahren
dass sie gekündigt worden sind es kann
nicht sein dass mit dem hinweis auf dem
wegfall der geschäftsgrundlage gas und
strom verträge plötzlich wegfallen nur
weil sich das gasunternehmen
verkalkuliert hat verträge sind
einzuhalten und unredliches verhalten
von gas und strom betreibern müssen
regulatorisch angegangen werden das ist
im sinne von verbrauchern und
verbrauchen
wir müssen auch über verbraucher
verträge sprechen wir haben in der
letzten wahlperiode mit dem fairen
verbraucher
vertrags gesetz die kündigung staaten
voran gebracht dass eine gute
einrichtung wir müssen das
fortentwickeln gehen auch zu einem
widerruf button im internet verträge
müssten so gekündigt und widerrufen
werden wie sie geschlossen werden das
ist eine frage von fairness im bereich
der verbraucher verträge
ich freue mich auch über die
erfrischenden und ehrlichen und uns
stolz machen den einlassungen des neuen
kollegen al hanak nicht nur in bezug auf
unser land sondern auch auf etwas was
gar nicht im koalitionsvertrag steht
aber es hat trotzdem gefordert hat
nämlich die automatische erstattung von
bahn
flugtickets wir haben das in der letzten
wahlperiode angemahnt und lassen sie uns
gemeinsam hier einen echten fortschritt
für die verbraucher nur verbraucher
erzielen wäre ein zugticket oder ein
flugticket mit der kreditkarte bezahlt
der kann noch erwarten dass er bei
verspätung in das geld automatisch aufs
konto zurück überwiesen bekommt meine
damen und herren
eine letzte große frage wird bleiben
nämlich die nach der regulierung von
plattformen algorithmen bestimmen
einkaufsverhalten und
schleichen sich praktisch in jedem
winkel des lebens wir brauchen mehr
transparenz und regulierung bei
algorithmen es muss klar sein nach
welchen methoden websites aufgebaut sind
und den verbrauchern beim verbrauch und
dinge angezeigt werden hier brauchen wir
einen
gesamtkontext und dieses thema anzugehen
es geht darum dass der verbraucherschutz
die menschen schützt und dass die
lebenswelten von klein bis groß
adressiert werden weil der schutz des
einzelnen kommen sie bitte zum schutz
der lebens umgebung für alle herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
und ich erteile das wort dem kollegen
jacob blankenburg spd fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe ministerin meine
damen und herren als erstes geht mein
glückwunsch zur erinnerung an sie liebe
frau ministerin lemke ich wünsche ihm
eine glückliche hand geduld verhalten
auch viel freude bei der amtsausübung
und ich versichere ihnen dass wir als
spd ein zuverlässiger aber vor allen
dingen auch ein vierer koalitionspartner
gemeinsam haben wir spd und grüne schon
einmal etwas großes in der umweltpolitik
bewirkt unter gerhard schröder und dem
damaligen umweltminister jürgen trittin
haben wir 2000 den atomausstieg
beschlossen und wir hätten heute einiges
weniger an atommüll wenn die
nachfolgeregierung das damals auch so
beibehalten
ich habe neulich einen sehr passenden
vergleich in diesem zusammenhang gelesen
mit der lehre und der lagerung des
atommülls ist es ein bisschen so wie
nach einer party werden aufgeräumt
werden soll dann machen sich die meisten
aus dem staub die rechnung wäre dann
auch keiner zahlt und zurück bleibt ein
schaler geschmack und ein runder kopf
und ähnlich verhält es sich dann auch
mit der atomkraft
wenn zum 31.12 dieses jahres das letzte
deutsche atomkraftwerk abgeschaltet wird
da bleiben insgesamt rund 1900 behälter
hochradioaktiven müll zurück
27.000 kubikmeter abfall müssen dann
sicher endgelagert werden einige
ewiggestrige wollen genauso weitermachen
und im gegensatz zu anderen ländern und
auch anderen parteien schenken wir keine
zeit an diese überlegungen zum
wiedereinstieg in die atomenergie was
ihr auch eine breite mehrheit der
bevölkerung nicht will und das ist auch
gut so
denn jeder cent der in den ausbau der
atomenergie fließt fehlt beim ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie und das ist das was
wir brauchen
statt debatten von gestern
weiterzuführen beschäftigen wir uns
heute mit der wichtigen zukunftsfrage
wie wir radioaktive abfälle sicher
beseitigen dazu ist in den vergangenen
legislaturperioden schon viel vorarbeit
geleistet worden ich denke hier an die
einsetzung der endlager kommission oder
die umfassende beteiligung der
öffentlichkeit und der wissenschaft
das war für deutschland ein völlig neues
verfahren es liegt zwar nicht alles rund
aber unterm strich
sich bewährt
mit dem standort auswahlverfahren
betreten wir neues terrain der
gesetzliche rahmen bietet uns stabile
leitplanken um uns sich hier sicher zu
orientieren bis 20 31 soll ein endlager
standort gefunden werden bis 2050
sondern endlager in deutschland
betriebsbereit sein aber dieser prozess
wird sicher nicht frei von konflikten
sein manchen wird das verfahren zu
langen dauern andere werden sich darüber
ärgern dass aus ihrer sicht die gesetze
nicht immer so wirksam angewendet werden
wie es möglich scheint und je weiter die
endlagersuche voran schreitet das duo
emotionaler werden die debatten geführt
und desto größer wird auch die druck auf
die der druck auf die politik werden ich
denke hier zum beispiel an die
regionalen verwaltung und
kommunalpolitiker die sich mit vielen
berechtigten fragen erwartungen und
forderungen aus der bevölkerung
konfrontiert sehen werden und trotzdem
wenn das verfahren angenommen wird
können wir eine neue stufe der
transparenz und partizipation in einem
für uns so wichtigen verfahren erklären
unser ziel ist es ergebnisse zu
erreichen die von einem breiten
gesellschaftlichen konsens getragen
werden und so sieht es auch das gesetz
vor das werden wir auch umsetzen
ja jakob die sag ich war hier für die
spd fraktion um in seinem redebeitrag da
kommen mir auch hier schon langsam zum
mehrere hier über die aussprache dessen
was für das ministerium für umwelt
naturschutz nukleare sicherheit und
verbraucherschutz in dieser legislatur
auf der agenda steht einiges haben wir
dazu gehört und das ist am ende dieses
ersten tages nämlich der bundestag
debattiert hier als drei tage lang über
die politik der ampel regierung das ist
am ende dieses tages schon eine kleine
vorausschau auf morgen auf den zweiten
tag im dichter knüpfen der bundestag und
auch wir mit unserer übertragung quasi
nahtlos an nämlich dann wird überall die
bereiche wirtschaft und klimaschutz als
allererstes hier debattiert werden ab 8
uhr 45 sind wir dann wieder hier bei
phoenix für sie da und werden diesen
ganzen tag verfolgen wo er die
verschiedenen ministerinnen und minister
und die ressorts sich vorstellen und
präsentieren was im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten wird und was die nächsten
vier jahre hier umgesetzt werden soll
das war es für heute ich darf mich von
ihnen verabschieden und bleiben sie
zweiter phoenix erfolg die tagesschau